malgré les mises en garde la corée du
nord a lancé sa fusée officiellement
pour mettre en orbite ce petit satellite
un prétexte pour masquer un essai de
missile capable d'atteindre l'alaska
le premier étage de la fusée s'est abîmé
en mer du japon le deuxième dans l'océan
pacifique après avoir survolé l'archipel
le troisième étage est tombé dans
l'océan lui aussi un peu plus tard
lancement était ratée mais la
provocation réussir réaction immédiate
de celui à qui ce défi est adressée en
tout premier le président américain sait
les règles doivent être respectées les
violations doivent être punies
les mots ont un sens le monde entier
doit s'élever contre la prolifération
des césar
car la corée du nord non seulement
possède des missiles mais tente aussi de
mettre au point une bombe nucléaire
un régime communiste stalinien qui a
ruiné son pays et son peuple et qui se
comportent en hors la loi je condamne
avec la plus grande fermeté cette
provocation il n'y a qu'une seule
réponse c'est l'union de la communauté
internationale pour sanctionner un
régime qui ne respecte aucune des règles
internationales
une opinion partagée par le monde entier
la réprobation est unanime à l'exception
de la chine et de la russie qui appelle
à la retenue
les états unis et le japon ont demandé
une réunion d'urgence du conseil de
sécurité des nations unies réunion qui
va débuter dans quelques heures